le puissant à paphos
un brave guerrier dans un monde où la
vue n'existe pas tous ceux qui sont
proches de toi finissent par souffrir
maintenant c'est ton tour mon frère
je m'étais juré de ne jamais y retourner
mais doit enlever ma fille
[Musique]
chic
je veux savoir où il a caché
qu'est ce que tu vois
le monde est sur le point de basculer
[Musique]
nous avons tous été choisis ils vont
instaurer un nouveau monde je portais un
enfant il viendra au monde doté d'un don
divin le don de la vue
la vue reviendra est la première nation
à exploiter ce pouvoir dominera le monde
je déclare la guerre la plus grande
puissance militaire du monde
ce n'est pas notre combat
si on s'en va il y aura des milliers de
morts c'est sûr et certain
[Musique]
connaissent et et demi j'ai deux sets et
demi
combattent pour asservir on comptera
pour être libre
prenez pas maintenant
[Musique]
et qu'on les accueille en enfer
[Applaudissements]
les des armes bien plus puissante que
l'épée la fronde ils détiennent les clés
de notre avenir
bienvenue chez toi bats
[Musique]